so first of all you want to know how to
graph the tangent graph y equals tangent
of X and that's what I have here and the
key thing to remember with the you know
these graphs is that they repeat so for
example I could draw another cycle of
the tangent and the same thing over here
it would also you know go like this over
here so it keeps repeating but the way
that it stands now is that the inverse
of this graph is not a function because
it fails the horizontal line test right
so if you draw a horizontal line it's
actually intersecting the graph at more
than one point so what mathematicians
decided to do is to restrict the domain
okay when they're graphing our tangent
and they're restricting the domain from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
this just happens to be one period of
tangent but in this fashion now it's
only going to you know the horizontal
line is only going to cross the graph at
most once so that means it passes a
horizontal line test the inverse of the
graph is a function and we can now you
know analyze it so what we're gonna do
here when you find the inverse of a
graph is you interchange the X and the y
values or the x and the y coordinates
and that's what we're gonna do here to
get the graph of arctangent now the
first thing I want to do is just label
these points so this point over here
negative PI over 4 comma negative 1
let's just go ahead and label that
negative PI over 4 comma negative 1
we're gonna interchange those values so
now we're gonna be graphing negative 1
comma negative PI over 4 now PI is
approximately 3 right so that means this
is about negative 3 fourths okay so I'm
just gonna approximate this to help us
graph it negative 1 negative 3 fourths
this point here at the origin that's
easy that's 0 0 ok and then this point
over here PI over 4 comma 1 which is
about again about 3/4 comma 1 so what
we're going to do is we're going to
interchange these values so 1 comma 3 4
0 0 that's already switched and negative
1 negative 3 fourths so let's go ahead
and plot those so where is negative 1
well negative 1 would be right about
here okay and then negative 3 fourths is
going to be right about here so I'm just
going to put put that point there 0 0 is
going to be right where it is right now
and then 1 comma
three force is going to be right about
here and right about here okay now the
next thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to take these vertical asymptotes and
when you reflect these vertical
asymptotes over the line y equals x this
45-degree line
what you end up getting is instead of a
vertical line you end up getting a
horizontal line so these asymptotes end
up becoming horizontal asymptotes and
they're going to be up here at PI over
two which is about one point five seven
so I'm just going to put them right
right about here okay and right about at
negative one point five seven so that's
going to be right about like that so now
what we're going to do is we're gonna
graph our tangent inverse graph it's
going to look something like let's see
here it's going to look like this and
what you'll notice is that it's a
reflection over this line y equals x so
if I sketch this in here okay this line
y equals x so it's a slope of 1 and you
can see that the original graph okay our
tangent our original graph which looked
like this is being reflected over that
line and here's our tangent inverse
graph like this so that's how you graph
the arc tangent of the tangent inverse
just take those x and y values
interchange them and then also make sure
to take those asymptotes and reflect
them over the line y equals x you get
these horizontal asymptotes up here at
PI over 2 and negative PI over 2 and
you've got it so I hope you enjoyed this
video subscribe to the channel check out
more math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mira's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon